all right let's talk debt limit the
republicans block the bill
needed to avert a government shutdown
this week and a federal debt default
next month the debt limit we're going to
go very elementary here the debt limit
it's a cap on the total amount of money
that the federal government is
authorized to borrow to fulfill its
financial obligations think of this like
an allowance that's essentially what
this is is what is the allowance the
federal government has to borrow to be
able to pay for things now the
democrats
are uh going what they want to do to
avoid the government shutdown they're
going to propose a short-term spending
bill that doesn't raise the debt limit
that can win bipartisan support so
essentially they just kick the can down
the road don't worry about the actual
debt limit uh just let's spend a little
more cash and the bill will most likely
keep cash flowing to government agencies
through december 3rd so it's not a
really long bill it's just through
december 3rd democrats highlight the
debt ceiling was raised three times
under president trump and the vast
majority of debt ceiling increases have
been bipartisan now i want to call out
two important things before we get to
all the quotes and charts that we have
first
they are not going to default this is
all a charade it's all a game
nobody that's a republican a democrat an
independent anyone watching this show or
anyone up here believes they are going
to default why because this is all
posturing and negotiating everyone wants
everyone else to believe we're really
serious oh we're really going to let it
default and everyone else is like no
we're really going to let it default
nobody's going to let it default this is
all posturing which is important because
we will see things happen here whether
it's short-term spending bills whether
there will be a debt ceiling increase
etc but
nobody believes that they are going to
actually default it is all posturing now
the second thing i want to call out is
that what we are watching is campaign
events as well so the democrats yield
the republicans the republicans yell the
democrats the independents sit there and
yell at both parties and this continues
around and around and around and around
and it doesn't matter if george bush
barack obama
or donald trump or joe biden or bill
clinton or ronald reagan or jimmy carter
is in office this game's been being
played for literally decades and it is
all about posturing campaigning and
trying to get your way in a negotiation
usually about things that have nothing
to do with the debt ceiling it's usually
about completely unrelated things or
things that are tangentially related but
it's not actually about the debt ceiling
so what we have here is we've got a
couple of different quotes first we're
going to go to mark warner the
democratic senator from virginia he said
we shouldn't even
string it out until thursday because of
the enormous costs that are incurred in
the pre-shutdown procedures but i think
we're there how do we get through the
debt ceiling still tbd so this is
essentially him saying i know that we're
not going to default i know we're going
to play the charade there's cost to the
charade but we shouldn't play the
straight we already know what we're
going to do let's go do it then we have
rosa deloro i believe so you pronounce
it the democratic representative from
connecticut who said she had purple hair
yeah oh really oh wow all right i'll
have to learn a story about that she
said quote i'm sure there are very very
smart clever people to figure out how
you deal with the debt our first order
of business is to keep the government
open which is we are which we are going
to do and quote scary
scary idea that we have politicians
saying oh i'm sure there's other very
very smart clever people to figure out
how to deal with the debt
well i think there might be a reason why
we want the politicians to figure this
[ __ ] out uh
but our first order of business is to
keep the government open uh which they
are going to do that i don't think
anyone up here or anyone watching this
or any of these folks believe that the
government's going to default do we all
agree on that
do you think they might default i think
there's a chance
what percentage chance i don't know to
be honest i i have no clue i've never
seen them default before i don't know if
it's even possible if that would let
that happen but i think the arguments on
both sides are getting to a point that's
just ridiculous and they both kind of
look like uh
they're both like staining their ground
for different reasons and i think they
both look a little a little dumb
we call this kicking the can down the
road that's what they're gonna do
so we have a chart here which that shows
the us debt rises irrespective of who is
in the white house and this is my main
point with this it doesn't matter this
is all posturing it's all politics it's
all campaigning literally it does not
matter the debt ceiling and the gross
federal debt at the end of the year in
the us from 1981 to 2021 keeps going up
we literally just keep going up
higher higher looks like a uh debt
ceiling looks like a deadline almost
dead ceiling look it's like every like
debt ceiling increased debt ceiling
increased debt ceiling increase this is
the game you can see here the red
republicans in office blue democrats in
office you can try to eye it up and say
well i think the slope is bigger when
the republicans are democrat they're
both doing this game and the reason is
because it has nothing to do with
politics it literally has to do that
they are in a game that they cannot get
out of they are caught in a catch-22
they are running a budget that does not
make any sense if you were to run the
united states as a business the united
states is not necessarily a business so
i understand why they don't do it but
the idea that we continue to take in
record levels of federal income tax
every single year since the global
financial crisis and yet we continue to
spend even more record levels of
spending year after year after year
tells you everything you need to know so
i appreciate the charade i love that
they are so good at acting that they
want to pretend like there could be a
default we're gonna pretend that maybe
possibly there might at a one percent
chance be a default
and then we're just gonna simply pass
this other thing that is gonna prevent
it so there is in my opinion
next to zero nothing zero but next to
zero percent chance that there is going
to be any sort of default because they
control and can make the decisions
meeting the democrats and there is
nothing that anyone can do to stop it i
tweeted this earlier government's awful
money managers most governments are but
this is turning out to be a perfect
storm for bitcoin
why
high inflation um arguments over the
debts you know government shut like this
is
the how like housing prices everything
revolving around the currency it's
turned out to be a perfect storm for
bitcoin and i can't wait to see the next
five to ten years hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're gonna build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help